oh we love us looks like a party
this looks spicy you look like some like
nachos but in the best subway possible
but it's like is it fruit and what's
this what is this just meat it's like a
tamarind candy very flavorful oh dude oh
this is great
oh my god they're like layering punch in
the face this was a myriad of texture
just there did it feel fuzzy
I keep getting like the most pungent
like the stream cause I think it's just
the whole thing
that looks yummy does it oh I look so
good I love cheese I love cheese - I
like the minute I like the mayonnaise
and cheese but not this I like the hot
sauce melt in my eyes I think the
mayonnaise a lot of people are afraid of
the mayonnaise I think it works I've
definitely had the white people version
this but like Six Flags where they just
like put butter on it does it'll win 5
out of 5 I normally don't like corn on
the cob but like having all these
flavors in it it's totally worth it
concept
already and a cup Oh mango girl mango
smells very good
I was like it does look all right it's
like a like a slimy warhead mm-hmm
those look like a beef jerky stick it's
a very very strong you bite you bite
this guy and go over that it's not so
bad when you take a good mango and Bend
that it's not bad though you like it I
do
smells like rich other is it or tub know
what's kind of chalky but it smells
really good
that is Fick got I got like a melted ice
cream texture and kind of does I think
that's why I like it this is jump will
travel right jump all happy oh it's like
the beginnings of a chai latte but it
didn't quite get there I don't know it
almost looks kind of like chunky like
somebody was eating
that's the masa sometimes jump will draw
those a little bit too sweet not my type
but this is this is pretty good after
eating cinnamon toast crunch using the
milk and then microwaving yes exactly
what it's like in this colorful and
vibrant and smells good it's like eat it
this is why with friends right